hello everyone and welcome back to the
opera euro rapid quarter finals is the
second day of the match the new duba
versus magnus carlson and yesterday
magnus really just mobbed the floor with
dubo he uh crushed him out of the uh
they didn't even get to play the fourth
game
because magnus only took three games to
eliminate dubai by winning two games and
drawing one
and now dubo needs to do the same he
needs to win day two in order for them
to go into
uh well into tie breaks uh so without
further ado let's check it out as it's
quite
uh quite a wild game so do with the
white pieces
opens with d4 we have knight to f6
c4 e6 knight to f3 and d5 we have the
queen's gambit declined
uh we have g3 by double and now bishop
to b4
with check uh we have bishop to b2
blocking and magnus goes back
bishop to e7 uh we have bishop to g2 and
now both players castle
so castles castles and now uh this
position has been reached
many times before magnus even had it
against the dingler and he played knight
beat to d7 against ding here
and a lot of other moves have been
played in this position but the move
magnus played
has never been played before and that is
a5 and it is already as of move 7 that
we have
a completely new game uh so let's see
how dubo deals with this and the magnus
took some three minutes on deciding what
to play here
so uh well quite a lot as it's still you
know the the first few moves of the
opening so queen to c2
and now c6 strengthening the center we
have rook to c1 by do both
uh and now comes uh knight b to d7 so
just continuing development
bishop to f4 by do both and now knights
the h5
challenging the bishop here so dubo goes
back and magnus says
all right i have the black pieces i'm
very happy with the draw i already won
the first match so knight h to f6 and
this is
definitely the the correct idea dubo
goes back bishop to g5 and now magnus
doesn't repeat
rather he goes h6 first bishop to f4 and
now again
knight to h5 so you cannot go bishop to
g5
next time the knight retreats so here
bishop back to e3 by dubo and
magnus again goes back knight h2f6
asking what
what is your plan here so duboff goes
back bishop to f4 and now again
knight stage 5. magnus doesn't care he
just goes back and forth
and here bishop to e5 and already the
situation on the clock is very
interesting dubo is down to 10 minutes
and magnus is down to nine minutes
uh we have knight h back to f6 by magnus
so this is like the fourth time he moves
the knight uh back and forth
knights the c3 dubo finally continues
development and now knight captures on
e5 we have d
captures and the knights the d7 going
after the e5 pawn
now we have capture sunday 5 e captures
on d5
and now rook to d1 and now queen to b6
by magnus so
the queen is very nicely developed
however here comes
e4 and now what do you play here uh well
you could of course
capture and uh then the knight just
improves the position
but here magnus goes for d4 and he says
uh
my development is much better and it's
going to be very dangerous for you to
capture this pawn
but you don't actually win material
because if you capture with the knight
then the knight can capture on e5 and if
you capture with the rook so the knight
keeps defending this you still capture
on e5 because the knight cannot capture
queen captures rook
so here you would have to play rook 8 to
d1 to defend the rook but now we would
see something like captures captures and
queen c5
and then the game continues with black
having just an excellent position
so here after d4 we have knight to e2 by
dubois
he doesn't uh grab the pawn he wants to
keep his e5 pawn there and now
bishop to c5 by magnus queen to c5 was a
bit more straightforward
but he goes for bishop here with ideas
of maybe pushing the pawn going for
bishop captures on f2
so now knight to f4 now the queen guards
the f2 square and
now rook to e8 by magnus uh we have rook
8 to c1 by double and you can see now
that duvel basically completed his
development whereas magnus still has to
figure out what to do with the light
square bishop and
the rook on a8 uh and here uh well
although you could play this in a in a
lot of different ways uh
magnus goes for d3 and this is super
dangerous because uh
well what what do you what are you gonna
do uh e6
is a a pretty big pretty big idea at
some point the knight cannot capture
because the bishop here is hanging so
uh what what can you do here if this
pawn moves
then ideas even like rook captures here
followed by queen captures bishop are
possible so magnus has to be very
careful
and he could in fact go for something
like knight captures on e5
it is possible and after giving up the
bishop queen captures and rook captures
go for this bishop to g4 idea with a
double attack on the knight here
and then uh of course if knight captures
then you lose the rook on d1 so here we
would see rook captures on e5
rook captures and now rook captures on
d4
followed by rook to c5 and the game
continues with white being better as
white has two knights for for a rook so
of course uh that's that's much better
but magnus
doesn't like this he decides to go for
d3 and this is now an incredibly
complicated position duba
has to figure out how to how to deal
with it and dubo decides to capture the
pawn with
uh with the knight and he plays knight
captures on d3 which is not
the absolute best way to capture rook
captures is much better
uh the thing is uh he was probably
probably afraid of knight captures on e5
but it doesn't work uh it doesn't work
because you have
rook to b3 and then you're just uh
you're just winning because the queen is
under attack if the queen
once you react to this uh the the the
bishop will fall
and there just aren't all that many good
moves here for black you could capture
an f2 with check but then we would just
trade the queen captures we would see
queen capture skin captures
and now knights the g for check but uh
again it's not uh
not much to look at the white is up a
piece and it's just uh just a better
position
so uh this was possible however dubo
decided to capture with the knight
saying that okay now i have a triple
attack on the bishop but magnus just
goes back
bishop to f8 and now knight the d2 going
for knight to c4
with an attack on the queen so magnus
quickly goes queen d4
and now knight to c4 and now comes
knight to b6
offering a trade of these knights and
now uh the
situation on the clock is that they are
both down to three minutes
so here knight to d6 by double giving up
a knight
or rather giving up uh giving up a pawn
uh and uh
it's very interesting what happens now
uh bishop captures on b6
e captures and queen captures so magnus
wins back one of the pawns but now
knight to c5 and again uh what would you
play here magnus goes for the
uh queen to c7 idea getting away fro
from the rook here and then now comes
rook the d for do both just defends the
pawn once again
and he prepares that to double up so
here knight to d7
uh magnus offers a trade rook c to d1
and now
knight captures in c5 queen captures and
finally
magnus solves all of his problems and
goes bishop to e6 and now that the light
square bishop has been developed and the
other rook can come into the game
he can simply trade everything off so a3
by dubo
and now rook a to d8 so definitely
a couple of great opportunities missed
so far by do both so here
we have f4 charging forward with those
pawns and b6 by magnus
queen to c3 and now even c5 pushing that
uh pushing that rook back with e5 now
the rook cannot be captured just yet
because the queen will be hanging
so here rook captures sunday for rook
captures again the rook
cannot be captured in the rook the d8
and here uh dubo just
trades it off captures captures and now
bishop to f3
saying that okay maybe maybe i'm going
to be able to push those pawns a little
bit in the future but
magnus uh now consolidates on the king
side the g6 with
h4 and h5 now both players with the
light square bishop
so it's uh it's not going to be easy uh
we have king to f2 dubo starts improving
the position of his king and now
b5 by magnus very tricky idea and even
though the material on the board is
completely equal
magnus has three points on the queen
side whereas duval has two and that's uh
being up a pawn on one side of the board
and it's definitely magnus who is
pushing here
so here you you don't want to capture
the the pawn if you capture the pawn
then black just uh
delivers check and wins back the pawn
and retains a better position now he's
going to create a pass pawn
it's going to be probably a very very
easy win for black
so instead dubo goes for bishop to e2
bishop to e4 was somewhat better because
you would have a lot more counter play
towards the king side but okay bishop to
e2
and now comes b4 by magnus queen to b6
uh was
a little bit better but i think magnus
was also playing on undo both time here
so here we have b4 by magnus immediately
starting to advance those spawns
but now dubo just captures the c5 pawn
we have queen captures
and now queen to d2 magnus is going for
some uh for some very very sneaky ideas
here with bishop to g4
so now queen captures on a5 duboff says
you've got nothing here
and uh indeed it's very interesting
bishop to g4
now threatening to to capture the bishop
here we have queen the a8
with check king to h7 and now queen to
e4 defending the pawn here and now
b3 and now magnus pushed this pawn all
the way he's
ready to capture the pawn on b2 now and
promote his past pawn
and there is only one move for dubois
that doesn't lose the game here so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
only
uh not losing idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
e6 e6 is extremely strong uh because
uh you have to react to it if you don't
react it than just i mean you get a
queen into the game
and other than that uh you clear the e5
square for your queen and that's the
only way you can defend the b2 pawn so
here
uh it doesn't matter what black captures
with the dupe of captured with the
bishop so bishop captures here
and now queen to e5 guarding the b2 pawn
and now
not a lot of ways for black to break
through bishop g4 again
putting the pressure on the bishop king
to f1 now unpinning
uh we have queen to c1 with check king
to f2 and queen back to d2 uh do both
again on pins queen to c1 check
king to f2 and king queen to d2 and it
was uh
in this position on move 53 that the
players agreed to a draw
or rather there's a three-fold
repetition going on so
there is no way for either side to make
progress so definitely a shame for duba
uh he had he gained the upper hand here
against magnus and he had a few a few a
few
positions where he could have played
better in the go for the win but it's
super complicated you're very long time
and magnus is just very very strong in
chess
so uh tough luck for dubai in game one
we'll see what happens in the other
three
can he catch up to magnus or will this
be another another day for
for a magnus win uh so that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank enrico salami and
narashman raghavan
tito reynaldo justin pollard and david
kimber for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice event uh
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day